[Music]
you remember the night we met
ladies and gentlemen of the jury you
have been witness to the unspeakable
horrors of the defendants heinous crimes
you have seen gastly injuries smashed in
faces broken jaws the defendant please
rise
for years I've carried this guilt but
I'm to blame for everything if we hadn't
trusted you promise you'll never leave
business it's about another material
isn't it
did did he do it no we've got a very
disturbed sick individual you'll be the
first nationally televised trial in
history
you look nice a partner I'm disguised as
an attorney today
I got very scared but you know he's also
really dreamy earthlings you don't know
that will shock you we aren't your worst
nightmares it's all I it is a capital
murder case and you are skating on thin
ice this is about catching a monster
[Music]
the killings were extremely wicked
shockingly evil vile did you do these
things Ted this is all gonna end it's
only gonna happen to turn
[Music]
[Music]
you